- [Mark] Okay, Alfredo--
Alfredo where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Alfredo] I grew up here
in La Puente California.
- [Mark] Okay, suburb of L.A.
- [Alfredo] Yes.
- [Mark] And, tell me about your family.
Had both your parents growing up?
- Yes, they were a old
fashioned Mexican family.
My dad took off really
early in my childhood.
I grew up with three
brothers and one sister.
And, pretty much you know,
I did the whole thing.
I went to--
You know, normal high school,
public school, I graduated.
You know there was, a bit
of alcoholism in my family
but nothing major, you know
it was just whatever you know.
But--
That's I mean, mainly it.
- [Mark] Yeah that's good.
So from when you left your parents house
and went on your own,
where'd you go from there?
You get married?
Do you have kids?
- Yeah.
Yes I have one girl.
She's already grown though.
But yeah, I--
After I graduated, and I
moved out of the house,
I got married.
About two years later I got married
to my high school sweetheart.
- [Mark] Are you still married?
- Well, I'm on the verge of
getting a divorce right now.
- [Mark] Okay.
- She already filed for divorce so,
all you know, messing up but,
it was inevitable and it's not solvable.
So, you know it is what it is.
It's better this way.
The good thing is that you
know, we only have one child.
Which she's already grown, so.
I'll be all right.
- [Mark] Where do you work?
- I work at an animal shelter in Pasadena.
- [Mark] Okay.
And so you like to come down to skid row
and pick up some of the ladies sometimes?
- Yeah, I probably do it every other day.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's a lot.
And, you'll come down during
the day or after work or--
- Well right now I'm not working.
I got hurt at work so, I
got all this free time.
(laughs)
And, yeah.
Usually I'll come out at night,
but sometimes I come out in the day.
- [Mark] And you have certain
girls that you--
- I have certain girls, yeah.
- [Mark] And you'll take 'em
in your car or hotel or--
- Yeah usually you know,
we'll do the thing in the car.
I'll drive out to one of
these abandoned streets
down here in skid row
and you know we do the thing, you know.
After that they get paid
and, I'm happy, I'll go home.
- [Mark] Yeah.
You ever had any shenanigans go on?
(Alfredo scoffs)
Like, a girl's
tried to rob you or?
- Yeah.
Not tried, have.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff--
- On a couple of occasions.
- [Mark] What do they do?
- One time this girl, we
pulled into a gas station,
she wanted condoms,
and so I pulled into a gas station,
(clears throat)
I don't know what I was
thinking but you know,
I left my wallet in between
the car seat and the console.
And I remembered that I had
some loose change in my pocket
so you know I walked
in, it was a 7-Eleven,
I bought the condoms.
When I came out, the girl was gone.
And so was my wallet.
About 600 dollars in there.
- [Mark] Ouch.
- Yeah.
So.
- [Mark] That goes with the
neighborhood doesn't it.
- It goes with the territory, right.
You know, so, but after
that it's a little bit
of a learning experience.
Every time I learn something new.
(laughs)
You know, and it's pretty
much, not to trust the girl,
you know what I mean?
But in time, I learned,
I met some girls
and I pretty much stayed
with those, you know?
So now it's like, sometimes I call
and they tell me to meet
'em somewhere around here.
I pick 'em up and you know that's it.
- [Mark] Yeah, so you developed
a little bit of trust?
- Well yeah, not all the way but you know,
with what I can, you know what I mean?
- [Mark] Right.
- I mean I've never
taken one of them to my house or you know
I've never given them my real names.
You know what I'm--
Stuff like that.
You know, I just wanted
to be safe, you know.
- [Mark] And you use
condoms when you do this?
- Yeah, I use condoms.
Once in a while, you know, I'll go raw.
Once in a while.
And it's because of
situations like you know
the ones when I pulled into the 7-Eleven.
But other than that I
mean, I use protection
as much as I can.
- [Mark] Yeah, I just think
there's some diseases down here
that you don't wanna
get anywhere close to.
- I really, I've been
you know knock on wood,
I've been pretty safe as
far as diseases go you know?
Because, I don't know,
this has become like
pretty much an addiction for me, you know.
I can't not do this.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I gotta come out and you know,
I gotta, can I say a bad word?
I gotta come out and get a blow job.
You know what I mean?
It's mandatory, you know?
So sometimes I have a little booze on me.
But it's become rather an expensive habit.
- [Mark] Do you think it's
gonna turn into something
where it would make it hard for you
to have a relationship with a female
that's not gonna have sex
with you on the first minute?
(laughs)
- I think yes.
I think eventually it
will because you know,
I have my wife or you know
if I meet another girl
or my girlfriend and stuff.
I don't know, I can't
do the things with her
that I can with--
You know?
So--
Yeah, eventually I think that
it's gonna get in the way
of my relationship,
because either she'll find out,
either I'll get arrested
god forbid or something,
and then, you know what I mean?
Then they call or whatever man.
You know she finds out that way.
I just don't want to--
You know I just try to
be careful, you know?
As much as I can.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- But if that ever get in the
way of a normal relationship?
It can.
But it also, you can contain it, you know?
Not forever, but you can
contain it, the best you can.
- [Mark] Have you ever been arrested?
- For this?
- [Mark] Yeah.
For that?
No, no, thank goodness I haven't.
I've been lit up with a spot light.
- [Mark] Oh is that right?
- During a session,
in my back seat.
But they were cool about it.
They just kept going.
Twice, matter of fact.
Once in the park, in Griffith Park,
but the one in Griffith--
Not in Griffith Park, in Legion Park.
But the one in Legion
Park, I was pulled over.
We were in a no parking zone
and the park rangers and a LAPD cruiser.
They got behind me, they put
the lights and like I said
we were you know, we were
getting busy in there.
And so, they gave me a ticket.
- [Mark] Oh you got a ticket?
- A vagrancy?
No not vagrancy, vagrancy right?
Is that what it's called?
- [Mark] Yeah, could be.
- So vagrancy, and parked
in a private property.
That's what the ticket was for, so.
I never went to court for it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Do you ever, even think about
the fact that these girls
are just doing it for money
so they can buy drugs?
- Do I think about that?
- [Mark] I mean,
they're not doing it because they,
I mean you're very handsome
and you seem like a good guy,
but--
- Thank you.
- [Mark] But it's not because
you're handsome and a good guy
it's because you have
money in your pocket.
- Damn right, yeah,
it's for the money.
- [Mark] Does it--
- I know that.
- [Mark] Does that thought
ever come into your head?
- It comes into my head, of course.
You know I mean but, I
don't feel bad about it.
You know I mean it is what it is.
That's their hustle.
Some are more expensive than others.
- [Mark] What's the most you've paid?
- [Alfredo] 80.
- [Mark] 80.
And what's the least you've paid?
- [Alfredo] 20.
- [Mark] 20.
And you'll have intercourse,
you'll have blow job,
you'll have whatever?
- [Alfredo] It all depends
on you know what my mood is.
And how much money I got.
- [Mark] Right.
- [Alfredo] It could go intercourse,
or I could just get some
head and that's it, you know.
- [Mark] And you have to be
drunk to do this you think?
- [Alfredo] No.
I have been but, I don't have to be.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Alfredo] I kind of like
it when I'm not though.
You know when I'm sober and
stuff so, because when I'm drunk
you know I kind of--
How do I say it?
The more I see--
The one's that I associate
with, they're pretty girls.
So it's like, sometimes
I get, I think to myself
"man, where has this chick been?"
You know?
Who has she been with?
How many dudes did she do this today?
Or, you know, and all that,
you know all that plays into
and plays a role in it and it's like,
I just trip out about it you know?
But like I said, that's their hustle,
I can't knock 'em for it and stuff, so.
- [Mark] Yeah.
All right, Alfredo, well thank you so much
for talking with to me.
- Hey you're welcome.
- And thank you for being
so open and honest.
- Oh yeah, no problem.
That's what it's about man.
(laughs)
- [Mark] Have fun tonight.
- [Alfredo] Maybe.
(laughs)
- [Mark] All right, thank you.
- [Alfredo] You're welcome.
- [Mark] You were great.
- [Alfredo] I am, I am.